[MUSIC]
>> Welcome.
Thanks for coming and
thanks to those online.
So, Mohammed and
I have collaborated a bit
over the past few years.
Mohammed's very well known
within the affective computing
community.
His recently known
program Chairs for
ACII the Affects of Computing
conference and spending a really
interesting work across a bunch
of different domains looking
at different types of sense
of data including EUG, and
facial expressions wearable
senses like EDA and heart rates.
So really excited to
hear his talk here,
and yeah, I look forward
to the discussions.
We'll have some time at
the end for questions, and
kind of further
follow-up from the talk.
But thanks, Mohammad.
>> Thanks, Dan, for
the introduction, and
putting notation as well.
Today, I'm gonna talk
about two different words.
But the experiments
were done together.
So I was doing one
experiment for
two studies with two sessions.
I'm going to go
through both of them.
This is my recent work.
And there's less physiological
signals in them.
For those of you if you
are interested in each you
would be disappointed.
[LAUGHS] A bit about
where I come from.
I work at The Swiss Center for
Affective Sciences.
It's a research
center on emotions.
We're mostly psychologists and
neuroscientists.
We also have people from
philosophy and just a couple of
people from computer science
who are interested in emotions.
So as I mentioned, I'm gonna
go through two studies.
The first one is about
visual interest.
I want to look into
the behavioral patterns,
and also physiological signals
if they vary by interest,
visual interest and images.
The second study is about
intent and image search.
I'm gonna give more
details later.
I'll start with the first one.
So what is interest?
So there are some people
who argue that interest is
an emotion, and
there are others who say that
this is purely cognitive.
But the ones who are for
interest being an emotion,
they say that interest is
an emotion because it has
consistent patterns in
facial expressions.
And it has an appraisal
structure.
So what does it mean?
Cognitive appraisals
are a set of evaluations we
go through in our mind, that
they can result in emotions.
This is based on the appraisal
theory of emotions.
For example,
if something happens and
then we evaluate that
stimulus or event and first
based on it's relevance, is it
relevant to me or my goals?
If it's not relevant,
we don't care.
So that doesn't
result in anything.
But if it's relevant then we go
through further evaluations.
For example, ok,
like for example,
there's a change in
the stock market price.
If you don't have any stocks,
you don't care.
So that doesn't
result in anything.
But then,
if you have then you check and
you say, okay,
can I cope with this?
Is it like did I
lose all my money or
it was just a small drop and
then that's the coping
potential, how
much you can cope.
Is it something, for examples,
against your norms or
values that also results
into something else?
The way it works is through all
these evaluations in your mind,
you get to the point
of having emotions or
having impure emotion changes.
So this psychologist Paul Sylvia
has pictures there, he
studied the appraisal structure
of interest and he identified
that novelty complexity and
coping potentials are the major
appraisals that they result in
interest and what do they mean?
Novelties, I guess it's more
clear if something is novel,
it can be more interesting.
The complexity,
is it the complex,
for example, he looked into
images and text, is it complex?
Like poetry, is it complex?
Is it comprehensible?
The comprehensibility, he
identifies comprehensibility as
the copy potential part for
this kind of stimuli.
So do we understand this has
the copy potential part for
this kind of stimulus?
And he also looked into
how people with different
personality traits get
interested in different things
and he found that openness to
experience is very important in
the way we put different rates
on these different appraisals.
For example,
if you are less open to
experience, then it's more
likely that you're interested
in more familiar things.
They found similar in, also,
in that friends, for example.
They found that people who
are less open to experience they
like kind of content that
is more pop, pop type
because this more familiar with
them it's easier for them or
they don't like to go into like
more complex type of music or
it's just a consistent pattern.
Also, in preference as well.
The other thing that some people
found was that pleasantness of
a stimulus is not necessarily
related to its interestingness.
So we can get interested in
something that's unpleasant,
either a car crash scene, for
example, which can be gory,
still catches your attention.
And it is interesting.
There are people who-
>> Did you see the recent,
I just heard on NPR so
I don't even have the citation
to give you, but watching horror
films is actually
effectively good for you.
It lowers all kinds of
physiological signals and
whatnot after the effect.
Super weird, I need to look it
up, I'll send you the link.
But it's unpleasant but.
[CROSSTALK]
>> There are a lot of people who
are looking why actually we get
interested in things that are
unpleasant or drama for example
that elicits sad emotions.
>> Yeah.
>> Why do we even like,
or sad music?
Why do we even like
to listen to them?
It's a very interesting life.
Although, as you will
see that actually,
what I found was not the same,
but you will see.
And I'll tell you why I
think it's not the same.
Regarding the recognition, or
actually looking at the patterns
of behavioral interest, there's
an older work from psychosis who
looked into the facial action
units that are actually like
the vocabulary that can describe
facial expressions based on
the muscles that they move,
for example.
Like you can describe the smile
based on some of the movements
on our face and these movements
from different muscles.
They are these like, they are
the things that you can use to
describe the expressions so
for example, mouth and
eye opener are these like units
of expression on face, and
they found these two to
be related with interest,
and the people who
work on this they can
maybe identify that these
are also maybe associated with
novelty if we see something
that's novel we open our eyes.
There are people who worked
on interest in education,
because that's
an important emotion.
Some people put interest
in a class of emotion
that's called knowledge, or
epistemic emotion, because they
say this is a type of emotion
that arises as a result of
an evaluation of our knowledge.
So it's important in education.
So in online tutoring,
for example,
they looked into
how student behave.
And then they found patterns
that are associated with
interesting-ness of the content.
If they are interested in the
content, not interesting-ness,
because interesting-ness is
related to the content and
not the person.
Worked on that a lot.
And there is also work on
interest and social interaction,
for example,
there is a work by that they.
They had two people sitting.
One was trying to
sell something, and
the other person was
asking questions.
And then they labelled the level
of interest of these people
afterwards by external
observers, and then they could
recognize this perceived
interest from their speech.
So the goal of what I did was
that I wanted to look into these
behavioral patterns of
appraisals that are related to
interest, coping potential,
novelty and complexity.
And I wanted to look
into to see if I can get
something from interest.
So we got 52 people
participating in an experiment.
We showed them 80 images.
Each image for five seconds.
And then we ask them to
self-report their level of
interest, curiosity,
coping potential, which is their
comprehensibility, novelty,
and complexity.
And then, we recorded
their video on case and
[INAUDIBLE] response.
The images were selected based
on their pilot study where
we selected about 1,000
pictures from Flicker.
I tried to find
a diverse set of images.
I was a bit hard on Flicker,
because when you search,
it always gives you the more
interesting ones or
the nicer pictures.
So I had to play a bit with the
API to also get the pictures on
lower quality or
less interesting.
And as you can see,
after I annotated them and
got labels for them on
Mechanical Turk, the ones that
they received the higher score,
these are normalizer scores.
So interestingness are the ones
that mostly depict action, and
then these are the boring ones
that are the least interesting,
that there's not much
to see in there.
And in order to actually get
a good idea, get a diversity
of people labeling, I also
got the Mechanical Turkers to
self-report, to actually fill
in the personality question.
So I could also get people
from low on openness and
high on openness, because I
wanted to look into whether
I can see that difference
that Paul observed.
As I mentioned, I had 52 people,
all healthy adult,
mostly female students, young.
And then, this is the set
up I used, the devices.
I use Tobi for just tracking.
Video was recorded with
an industrial camera and
[INAUDIBLE] response.
I recorded because there
is this study from Lang and
the International
Affective Picture System,
that they find the strong
correlation between interest and
arousal, their level of
emotional activation.
And I wanted to see if I can
see this in in response to
electrodermal response.
Just looking at these self
reports I received from
these people,
I could see that actually,
interest is mostly
correlated with curiosity.
Because actually, curiosity,
some people say it's the same.
Some people even say that
intrinsic motivation is the same
as interest.
Then how do you interpret that?
But you can see there is
a higher correlation and
significance between novelty,
complexity, and interest, and
not much with coping potential.
Even under, yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> That was
the comprehensibility.
And I actually show you in
the next slide why there's no
correlation, because actually,
there's no data [LAUGH].
Because all the pictures
are all comprehensible.
That's the problem.
It's a very strict distribution.
And I calculated
Chromebox off just to see
if the ratings I collected were
reliable, and they are reliable.
That doesn't mean that they
were consistent because
people are interested
in different things.
It just tells you that this
was not random assignments.
They actually rated them.
So here you see why coping
potential just didn't work,
because this is
actually inverse.
Everybody was high on,
I mean, [INAUDIBLE].
Of course,
the pictures on Flicker,
there's nothing
incomprehensible in them.
So there wasn't
much to see here.
But one thing that we
consistently found was that
pleasantness was correlated
with interesting.
If somebody was pleasant, people
found it interesting, let's say.
And it could be a bias
of our data, yes?
>> Sorry, so
pleasant is on the y-axis?
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Where is the pleasantness?
>> I don't actually have it,
I'm just telling you.
>> [LAUGH].
>> It's not on this
slide, sorry.
But I just want to tell you that
we did not find the same thing
that was reported, but it could
be also bias of our data,
because we did not have
extremely unpleasant,
let's say, images maybe.
And, yes?
>> So would the opposite of
pleasantness be unpleasantness,
or would the opposite of
pleasantness be boring?
>> No, unpleasantness.
Although some people might view
that these are actually not
bipolar, and
we should ask them separately.
But we could see that at least,
it seems for
interest, we could get kind
of a uniform distribution.
We succeeded in actually
having people reporting
a different sets of scores.
>> [INAUDIBLE] X and
Y axis for me.
>> Actually,
these are histograms, sorry.
So these are just, let's say,
the percentage of the ratings
received from everybody that
referenced this one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
So this just shows-
>> On
the bottom is
the liquor grading.
>> Yeah, liquor, and that's
the percentage I normalized.
>> Percent of people,
yeah, okay.
>> Not only people but
instances.
Because here, we can see
that most of the items
were reported as being very low,
and
let's say incomprehensive,
high incomprehensive.
I looked at faces.
I detected action units with
an open source libraries called
OpenFace.
And then from eye gaze,
I also looked into and
stuff, but here what I
show is the head distance.
Because I thought the distance
between the, because I guess it
also measures the distance
between eyes and the tracker.
And I thought that was maybe
a measurement from the posture.
And I just looked at the raw
signal that I showed you, and
you just saw.
One thing that I could
observe was that people,
the way they interpreted
interest was not the same.
So some people,
I think they had the idea that
if something is pleasant,
it's interesting.
And you can see that they showed
this kind of expressions.
And then if something
was confusing or
something was unpleasant,
they reported that it was
very low on interestingness.
And I mean, for this guy,
it was more like maybe
there was more attention.
>> Sorry,
I have a question about this,
I don't quite understand.
So it is the person in
the picture looking at something
that they rate interesting or
disinteresting?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So if I just correlate
between the action that is
detected and
the report that, let's say,
on the level of interest, and
curiosity, coping, [INAUDIBLE],
etc., you can see these are the
action units that they came up.
The correlations are not very
high, but they are still
significant because we
have a lot of samples.
But you see that the most, this
is the most salient ones that.
Actually, 12 and 6,
which are about smiling.
So since smiling comes up,
it correlated
the interest the most.
And the other ones that come up
are not related, for instance,
to novelty.
It's actually 5, and
this is also something that was
reported to be correlated
with interest.
After it actually not getting
the very nuanced, and let's say.
Significant results on just
looking at action units,
I talked to some colleagues who
are also working on interest and
developmental psychology, and
they told me the same thing that
They also don't see something
that's just consistent in the
[INAUDIBLE] if you just look at
the expressions,
if you just average.
And they taught me that, and now
they published these results,
is that it seems that for
interest, what matters the most
is not the type of expressions
but the dynamics of it.
Because they ask people
to actually even identify
interests, so
they showed them different
images of an actress actually.
And what they found was what is
identified as an expression of
interest has a certain pattern
that they called freezes and
approach.
So there is this moment
that you freeze, and
then you approach something
that's interesting.
So what I did after was that
I took just the most extreme
parts, like the ones that
were clearly interesting and
the ones that were clearly
uninteresting, those results,
and I just looked at them.
And I'll show you some results.
So looking at the distance
of people to the screen,
that's something that I
recorded, [INAUDIBLE] structure.
You can see that for the samples
that were reported low on
interesting, there's not
much change over time.
But for the ones that
are very interesting,
they have this kind
of freezing approach.
So first, there's this one
second that they are constant,
and then they start actually
getting closer to the screen.
This starts from zero, because I
baselined with the distance from
the start looking at the image
just that they are comparable.
>> This is less,
this about an inch.
It's less than an inch, right?
But they're moving closer.
>> This is, yeah.
>> Two centimeters?
>> Yeah.
>> So it's pretty subtle.
>> Yeah, and they couldn't
also move that much,
because I instructed them
not to move too much,
because otherwise I
would lose their gaze.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE] stretch,
it's like they could move.
I didn't put them on a chin
rest, but still I told them not
to move too much, otherwise
the distractions [CROSSTALK].
>> Is there even more approach?
I mean, because I was kinda
surprised to see that it would
also transfer to adults.
>> And that's with [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, because that would I
think that'd be a big approach.
Adults would probably be more-
>> Infants what they did
was that actually
somebody acted.
So they had two objects hidden
and there was an actress.
So she acted the expression
of interest and
the infant could see two hidden,
there were two curtains in
front of two objects that
the infant couldn't see.
And they wanted to see which
one the infant reaches to grab.
They kind of said that we
supposed that the one that's
more interesting, that the
actress showed more interest,
would be more interesting for
them to go and explore.
That was the other study.
The galvanic skin response,
there is not much
difference between them.
I was hoping to see
maybe some difference.
I also looked into the face
response, there wasn't much.
But I think it maybe
there's not much emotional,
let's say, content in them.
The head pose we can see
some difference, I mean,
not very large.
But you can see there's
a pattern of like it seems that
they moved their head down
when it was more interesting.
Maybe they want to
concentrate on the content.
And this piece here actually
just measures the size of
the face detected, so it's very
similar to the distance to
the camera [INAUDIBLE] that
was on top of the screen.
A bit lower actually,
that's a precision,
because the face-tracker
has a better measurement.
Looking at the expressions,
just like averaging the
intensity of the expressions.
So obviously the 6 and
12 that are about smile,
you can see there is some
difference over time.
But they're hoping to see
something in action units one
and two.
It seems it's action unit two
doesn't get detected very well
with the open face, and we don't
see that much difference in one.
And also seven that is
about lip closure or
I think lip tightener.
We can see a very
small difference that
the face that's more active and
[INAUDIBLE] interesting.
>> How long did they
look at each picture?
>> How long-
>> Yeah, how many seconds?
>> Five.
>> Just five seconds?
>> So these are actually you
see the seconds one, two-
>> And a few slides back you had
the GSR numbers, and
the tonic GSR takes a good six
to ten seconds before it even
starts to react to anything.
>> Yeah, but the problem
is that then they start
the self-reporting, so
I can't really, I think it's
just too short for GSR.
>> Yeah.
>> You could have
done ten seconds,
that's what Andy's saying.
>> Then I thought maybe
they'd get bored.
[LAUGH] I don't know.
>> [CROSSTALK] is not the right
one for a short study.
>> I don't think, maybe it's
not for this kind of stimuli.
Just to summarize, what we found
was that it seems that people
interpret interest differently.
Some people found something that
was more interestingly pleasant,
more interesting and some
people had a different idea.
We didn't find we did a presence
of action as to be a very
strong, let's say, indicator
of interest in this setting.
And I think that maybe freezing
approach hypothesis should
be further investigated.
Maybe there's something
there to look for.
Yes?
>> Can these
expressions be faked?
>> Yes,
what is the motivation of faked?
>> No, they can end
the application, right,
to come up with
the idea that okay,
these expression [INAUDIBLE]
saying that okay,
this person isn't interested and
that person is not interested.
But if someone knows that I
was on the hierarchy, okay,
these are the typical
expressions.
And then they can fake
it as well, right?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> But while taking the GSR
scores we picked up, because
it's electrical signals and-
>> But
also connecting them
would be also difficult.
>> Sorry?
>> Collecting them, recording
GSRC results you need this,
you need electrodes, and
they have to be placed.
Even the wristbands
are don't always record.
>> Well, that absolutely brings
up the question of using
the mechanical turkers.
So was there any kind of reward
for producing more interesting.
Or I'm just wondering if
there was a possibility that
the interpreters could be led
produce a type of response
that was more
exaggerated than normal?
>> I don't think so.
I mean, the recordings were done
in lab, the expressions, so
it was not from [INAUDIBLE].
>> I see.
>> It was just the first ratings
that I collected just to
select the set up sample and
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Are you thinking of like for
the face recognition feature
that you might fake it?
>> Yes.
>> Did you look for
identifying differences
in gender, by gender?
>> No, but usually we know that
humans are more expressive and
they also report more
emotions on average.
But I don't know what interest.
I mean obviously the picture of
the naked woman has a different
pattern of interest in gender.
It depends how you
define gender but-
>> You didn't look at it because
you had mostly females?
>> No, I didn't look at it
because I didn't think that it
was a question for this.
I don't know.
I was hoping that I would get
something across the line of
the personality traits and
other things.
But I couldn't get the same.
I think the difference between
what I did and what Sylvia did
is that [INAUDIBLE]
Sylvia the psychologist.
I think he used
the visual poetry.
So they are really
complex stimuli, and
here you have differing images.
They are comprehensible
in over there.
They are not really complex, so
you can't really get the same
kind of fact from these points.
Or he use used polygons.
It is very abstract
with a couple ridges.
>> Did you look at the other
four categories of Beta five
other than openness?
>> I didn't because the others
did get any result,
I though that was-
>> So you did look at them.
>> No I didn't look at them.
The prior work didn't find any.
>> Because the psychologists
didn't find anything.
>> Because we always see things
with neuroticism for instance.
Always get it from neuroticism.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
I have actually more data for
that because all the about 200
people on Mechanical Turk that
they record-
>> Yeah,
you should look at the others.
>> No,
I should look at the others, so
because I have a lot more and
like ratings than just logic.
>> You might get
stronger results.
>> So, now we get to
this part that's intent.
So, what is intent?
So, this is a work that
I wanted to look into
how behavior varies and
emotions vary by
different underlying
motivation for search.
For example, you wanna look for
an image to use for
your, like slides.
You want to look for an image
to just entertain yourself.
You want to look at cats,
or you may want to look for
an image you have in your mind.
So these are like,
this is what I mean by intent.
So you just have different
underlying situations when you
start your search.
So here, we want to look into
this like why a user performs
search and how it affects their
behavior when they do search.
We know that from web search
that there are existing classes
that are identifies for
example navigation.
You want to find a certain
website, when you do a search
for information, you want to
find something out, transaction,
you want to do something, you
want to pay a bill for example.
But the intense in
multimedia search is a bit
different from web search for
images and
video people,
I'd identify different classes.
For example, for images, there's
still navigation, although
I don't really understand how we
can have navigation with images.
There's transaction, you want
to use the image for something,
you are looking for an image
to use for certain purpose.
Knowledge orientation, you
want to understand something,
that's more about information.
And mental image,
you have an image in mind
that you want to refine
on the in snap.
For videos, for example,
there is again information,
experienced learning.
You want to know how to tie
a tie, you go on YouTube,
and if you're like me who
doesn't know how to tie a tie.
Or experience exposure, you
want to see how it looks like
to do a certain crazy action
then you can go and watch it.
And affect, so you want to
cheer yourself up, you go and
watch cat videos, for example.
And also object if you're
interested in certain object
that you want to
observe in the video.
And even search engines now,
they consider these things
based on the queries.
They classify queries and
then they give you results that
are not only relevant, but also
in terms of information, what
they are giving you something
that is probably also relevant
to the underlying motivation.
For example, if you look for
They give you other
recommendations as well
that they know that, okay,
you might not be necessarily
looking for this person but
you want to just look
at soccer players.
Or you might want
to also form like
they say that celebrity searches
about information information
about other people
who are relevant.
There is work by Moshfeghi and
Jose that's published in 2013.
They looked into
how emotions and
interactions vary under
different search intent for
videos and they used
three classes of intent.
They elicited this, so they gave
different scenarios of search.
I use the same almost but for
image, seeking information,
refining content,
and entertainment.
But they had two types
of entertainment,
adjustment by mood, and
adjusting by arousal,
and adjusting for mood.
So you want to
cheer yourself up,
you want to make yourself
calmer or more excited.
They found differences
in the reported emotions
across the when they start
at the middle and the end,
they ask people to report.
And they found different
types of experiences
in different type
of search intent.
And they did some intention and
they tried to recognize what
intents they had from
their behavioral patterns.
There are also work that they
looked into user logs to see
actually what they find
from real user log data,
just on Yahoo.
And they found that there
are like, if they look at,
let's say,
the most common search.
They found that celebrities and
animals are very prominent,
let's say,
in terms of statistics.
There are also fashion items,
cars and
graphics like clip arts.
And then they want to associate
the type of query with intent,
and they also ask people
who perform search.
And obviously clip art
is about transaction.
You wanna use the clip art for
something.
And then celebrities about
knowledge, orientation,
or information.
When they ask people why
they look for celebrities.
So what we want it to do was to
look into emotional reactions
and look into how the implicit
interactions like clicks and
mouse movement and key strokes.
The value under these different
search conditions like
the different intent but we also
looked into the visual content,
the images they visit when
they do search under these,
whether just to see that
the type of image they visit is
different that we
thought it should be.
And then we want to do also
recognition, we want to see if,
very early in
the search session,
we can recognize the pattern
that's associated with this kind
of different intent.
Maybe a system could
recognize that,
and maybe you would rank or
update the results.
So the setup was used, but
we kind of simulated seven
different search sessions.
So they were receiving
an instruction,
they were doing some search.
Every search session
was three minutes.
And at the end of
this search session,
we asked them to
self-report emotions.
And also exactly about how
much they were in control.
Because we want to
record eye gaze,
we couldn't use the let's
say that traditional,
not traditional but
the conventional interface.
So we made our own with
Flickr API, because we wanted
the thumbnails always to
appear in the same place so
we can look at
the gaze patterns.
So the thumbnails were always
there and let's say the enlarged
image was always there so
we could make heat maps.
So, we had three sessions for
finding,
that was more like transactions.
We gave them instructions, go
find pictures, for example, for
advertising Geneva to tourists.
We chose Geneva because the
subjects were I'm more familiar,
so tell them okay,
find something that shows this
square, and there were three
sessions we gave them example
images that they had to kind of
memorize, and try to refine, and
then there was also
the last condition,
we only gave them once
because it gets boring.
That was entertainment, go find
something to just entertain
yourselves, look up
the images you like.
We didn't leave different ones
because it's very hard to
adjust arousal just by images,
it's not like videos,
videos they have more content.
This is an example
So they start searching.
So there's this part
that they start and
they read the instruction and
we did the analysis and
we throw that part away when we
did the analysis, so we excluded
the inch of let's say seconds
and you want to then add this.
Then they start-
>> Then the red
button is the gaze?
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting.
>> So these are the fixations
and seconds, so
where they fixate and
you can see there is correlation
between mass, movement, and.
>> I'm wondering, so
you seem to be predominantly
be looking at the right side
of the and not so much left.
It's that [INAUDIBLE] the search
parameters [INAUDIBLE].
So he types in the thing,
and just looks down, and
sees what he [CROSSTALK].
>> That's true, that might
actually introduce some bias.
>> Maybe we should say
it's within the middle.
>> Cuz they probably do
the grid s curve of scanning
an image is pretty typical.
So they might end it
there on the right.
Okay, so for this one we
wanted to actually look into
the classes of emotional
expressions like fear, anger,
happiness, things like that.
So we used from the something
that Dan created partly.
And we also looked into.
The features from
the maybe the one
that's entertaining is
maybe more exciting and
we looked into also ideas and
how the fixation,
number of fixations
the patterns of.
The preview violation and
the distance varies.
We also record the interaction,
the mouse cursor movement,
the trajectory, the speed,
so we extract these features
from these distance it actually,
it goes around the path that
goes around the screen.
The locations of the clicks,
whether they clicked
on the thumbnails,
they clicked on the next page so
it is like recalculate
the frequency of these events.
We just from the keys, we just
looked at the keystroke rate.
We also looked into the queries
to see how they vary, so
we calculated something that
we called query complexity and
we calculated that based on
the ambiguity of the word.
So we looked into the word
net to see how many sub-trees
are under that words.
Say okay is this
a very specific word,
or is it a very let's say more
generic word that was used?
We extracted some visual
features let's say some more
general features like texture
features or edge features.
But we thought maybe there's
also something emotional so
we used this visual
sentiment detector
>> So it recognizes visual
concepts that are related
to visual sentiment.
For example, a feral cat.
So these are not necessarily
concepts that have emotions,
but they identified these visual
concepts to be important for
expressing sentiment in images.
Looking at the self reports we
can see that for example so
these are three conditions
of entertainment,
finding, and refining.
Finding is the transaction, so
the interest was the highest
in entertainment because they
were looking at things, and
browsing things that they liked.
And obviously boredom
was the lowest so
these are the ones that
we asked them to report.
Interest, boredom, confusion,
control, and surprise.
We asked them to tell us
how much they felt in
control because over two of
these sessions we also tried to
obstruct their goals.
So we injected and removed
their query terms by random.
But after we looked at these
perception of control,
it seems they actually
didn't identify that we
were manipulating
the query terms.
>> Sorry,
I keep asking questions, so
on the y axis is
perception of control?
>> Yeah, it's.
Yeah, so first impress, boredom,
confusing, control, yeah.
And they're different.
>> I think different axes
would help a lot [LAUGH].
>> Sorry I didn't do labels.
>> Slides.
>> So what does the first
one means, for example, for
the interest?
>> So interest is highest
on the entertainment.
I'm sorry but
how do you define [INAUDIBLE]
adjustments to a normal search?
>> So these are the different
conditions they search things.
So they were step in search
sessions and then they had
different instruction and
defined conditions,
they had to go find pictures for
this purpose, for example,
go find pictures to advertise
Geneva and show the lake.
And refined?
>> Refined is that we
show them one image and
we ask them go
find this exactly.
>> Ok, I see.
>> And it seems that refined
was the most confusing
although there was no
significant difference.
I think here and control,
obviously entertainment was
the highest in control.
Surprise, it seems that
there wasn't much surprise.
[CROSSTALK]
>> How would you define that
query terms chart?
>> So query terms is just,
this is the number of
query terms they used.
So it's-
>> Most for refunding
>> So the image for
refining they were shown, were
they given any context about it?
Or it was simply an image?
>> No it was simply an image.
>> Ok, and is that, query terms,
per query or
over the whole session.
>> It's over the whole session.
I think what happened
was that entertainment,
they just used a very short
query and they just browsed.
So it was more browsing
than searching.
>> But in the refine
it was the one let's say the one
that they reformulated queries
the most because they wanted
to find that specific one.
>> Because given an image it
might be an abstract information
for the consumer so
they might be typing more words
to explain what the image was.
Maybe that's the reason the
query has a higher view point.
>> Also with finding they only
have to find, like if you say go
find pictures of Geneva that
we can use for advertisement.
They know Geneva well there,
there's many many images of
Geneva, they only basically
have to search for
Geneva, Milan, whatever
the [INAUDIBLE] The thing
is whereas [INAUDIBLE] if they
don't know what that thing is
they're really going to
have to find a term to
describe it [INAUDIBLE]
that's going to make a long.
>> And the other things is that
when you have very specific
image sometimes like what.
The first query
doesn't read anything.
>> The other thing I'm wondering
is the amount of time they spent
doing the searches.
I would think that the amount of
time they spent on entertainment
would be higher because
they're interested in it.
And the amount of time they
spent on refind would be higher
because they have to find
an exact result, but.
>> Yeah, but the sessions were
>> I mean there's the whole
three minutes.
>> Okay.
>> So we looked into actually
four because at least for find
and refine there was a way for
them to give us feedback that
they identified the image.
So we looked into how much they vary
>> And
we also looked into how many
pictures they looked at,
thumbnails, and
was the highest refined.
But the differences
are not that large.
>> Is that an average?
>> This is average.
>> On average 250.
>> No, but
these are not the enlarged ones.
These are the thumbnails.
>> So per query 250-
>> So,
what's it on a page or
something?
>> No, no, over a session.
Over a three.
>> Please describe.
I do not understand
the details about that.
[LAUGHS] So, you mean,
over the whole session?
They will get 250 individual
thumbnails on-
>> I'm not sure they actually
looked at them.
I didn't count their
facial fixations, but-
>> Pass.
>> But, this was shown,
let's say.
>> I don't [INAUDIBLE].
How did they [INAUDIBLE].
>> Because like the ten
images here, for
example, so
that's 20 going to 25 pages.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> So-
>> Yeah, if it,
yeah it's pages worth of images.
That's still a lot
of three minutes,
cuz that's really just click,
click, click, click.
>> For the refined,
let me show the gaze pattern,
because that might help.
Cuz what was happening for
the refined.
Let's see, was that they were
mostly looking at the timelines,
because they want to
spot the picture.
So they were just going through.
This is the refine, you can see
that most of the time was spent
just clicking on the next,
and the queries,
they were not spending that
much time with the, they
are not enlarging the picture-
>> Yeah, so that 250 is really
misleading, what they're really
looking at is much smaller.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, so
it's misleading, yeah.
>> Well I think 250
images in 3 minutes,
that implies a scan, and
I don't think that's misleading-
>> Exactly.
I think that is saying
they scanned 250
>> You can see exactly how many
they actually looked at,
you can count them
>> It is hard to do with
the S tracker, people see more
things than the S tracker shows.
>> Really?
>> Because they have peripheral
vision.
>> Peripheral vision,
yeah maybe they will see it.
>> So, So
these are the numbers of
the clicks they made on
different parts of the page.
So these are absolute
numbers of clicks, and
these are different conditions.
And you can see that
some are a bit different,
like they marked more
images in the find,
meaning that they clicked to
actually enlarge the image, or
they clicked more than the
search button and the refine,
because they were
searching more.
Sorry, this was just
a thumbnail enlarging.
It seems that they looked at
the enlarged picture more,
when they were in
the entertainment condition.
>> What is statistically
significant on this?
>> So
this is all in the paper, but
I don't remember
all of the details.
But I think this one was
significant, certainly.
I think I did, some of these.
But, all the statistical
details are in your paper, and
I don't remember them all.
I also looked into actually,
how these things vary over
time in a search session,
not only in average, but
how they varied over time.
And it seems that, the query
complexity, the one how
generating the term is that they
used to query for the search.
It also varied, but
under different conditions.
And actually for entertainment,
was the most specific terms,
because they exactly new what
they liked to look at for
refined, they were formulating
more generic terms to identify,
to find, let's say those,
content that you
want to look at.
So, I looked at the sentiment
of the query terms they used,
because I thought maybe
the sentiment of the terms, and
the under entertainment is
different from the sentiment
under other conditions.
I looked at both images
sentiments, with your sentiment,
let's say tried to use this
system that identifies,
whether this image
is just as polite,
whether this is pleasant,
or unpleasant, and
I also used a language in
a query on word count.
Just the lexical model method,
to get the sentiment
of the query terms.
But I couldn't see any
difference in these different
conditions, cuz there
was no difference.
This the heat map
averaged over everybody.
And what you can see here is
that, they were scanning as you
said, you can see that
they were just scanning,
especially in refine condition.
You find they were also like
spending more time looking at
the thumbnails.
And only in entertainment,
they were looking at
the larger picture.
We then extract that features
that similar features I
mentioned, from the first
10 seconds, 20 seconds and
30 seconds of the session,
to do recognition,
to see if we can
recognize this three.
You leave one participant
out cross-validation,
we use the First classify
these two classes, and
then we fuse these different
features, visual and
interaction, and
then expressions.
These are the results,
the best results are from
the implicit interactions,
the mass movements and
key strokes, things like that.
Mouse clicks, and
the visual features.
The face is not that bad, but
I don't think that actually,I
think it mostly comes
from head pose,
not actually from
facial expressions.
But what I can tell here is
that, the we cannot be sure
that these are actually intent
we are classifying, because we
might just be classifying the
type of task that we were doing.
So, I think we need a larger
study to be sure that this is
actually right. Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE] More so
to whether language
is to search for
entertainment search for
finding, or search for request?
>> Is that at two classes.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> So what we learned was that,
the query terms,
eye gaze pattern,
the browsing behavior,
it varies under these
different conditions.
We found some differences
in the visual content,
they visit less than
their visual features.
And we saw also some difference
in their reported emotions, but
we saw very,
very little facial expression,
like in terms of action in it,
or we even looked
at like these classes of
expressions recognized.
But we couldn't see any
differences across different
intent classes.
Just credit to my
colleagues who helped.
Marcello, who's a psychologist.
We worked together for
the work of interest.
And the work of
intent I collaborated
with Michael Riegler, and
Pal Halvorsen from Norway.
And acknowledgements for people
who funded our research, and
gave us the experimental
facilities, thanks.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> More questions?
>> Will the slides be available?
>> Pardon me?
>> If you want I can
make them available.
>> Okay, sure, thanks.
>> You're welcome.
>> So, all right, in the end you
talked about that there was very
little facial
expression difference,
between the different denture
casts, and could you add to
a future experiment where you
could ask them to look for
Images that would be
designed to induce emotion.
Like look for horrific images,
look for super happy images,
look for things that are like
weddings or cat videos,
something that would be more
likely to induce something.
So you can see whether
it's the task or
it's the image that
they've received.
>> I think the best somebody
could do is to add personal
pictures, because those are the
ones that you actually feel
that there's some relevance.
And then you will have
stronger emotions,
then you have real interest,
because that's relevant to you.
Because whatever picture
we retrieved from Flickr,
you probably don't care
about that [INAUDIBLE].
>> That's the most important
thing in search experience.
>> But the problem is it's
a tough thing to do in
this kind of setting to
ask people to share their
personal [INAUDIBLE].
I don't think,
>> You can ask them upfront in
a survey.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Like that,
we're really happy with [LAUGH].
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> I don't know.
>> So follow up on that, so
how many, how did you come
up with the refined tasks?
Because I imagine you have
visual content, [INAUDIBLE]
extracted, the actual images and
query terms [CROSSTALK].
Yeah, how did you
come up with that?
>> So these three classes
were very similar to the ones
of the paper in 2013 that I
mentioned about video search.
So we wanted to see if we can
get similar let's say results.
>> The actual specific, when
they were all defined x or y,
how did you come up with
how many people were there?
>> I just chose the ones
about transaction.
The ones that they had
to use it for tasks.
I came up with the idea
of using just tourism ad
because I thought that this is
something that's accessible
to everybody who participates.
Because otherwise if I gave them
different, like a very specific
task, I was afraid that
they can't even do it or
they don't have any
idea how to do it.
>> Okay, so it's just
the tourists, that was just one?
>> Yeah, but
like different type of let's say
pictures for tourism.
Find something that
doesn't have a lake,
or find something that
has this special square.
>> What would you describe
as a real application
of the [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Well, one can be to actually,
to identify that
early in a search session
to may be [INAUDIBLE] or
to even, Even use it to,
let's say,
classify queries for
different intent classes.
Because I think what
a search engine does is
that they are probably
never gonna do looking at
the behavior of the image.
But they are gonna
look at the query.
Cuz if they receive a query, and
they know that this query is for
this intent,
they are more likely to show
you a different thumbnail for
the image, or even a thumbnail
for a video, for example.
Because they can choose these in
thumb nails [INAUDIBLE]
>> But
that could be possible only
if you had an X-ray, right?
How about they show a condition
that you are losing hair,
[INAUDIBLE] what is the intent?
Won't that be
applicable as well,
because from back it looks like
If I am now- if I am searching
when the camera is on,
I wouldn't be very comfortable-
>> No, no,
that is not something
that you can use and
I don't think that anybody would
be comfortable with having
their [INAUDIBLE].
That we use their camera
when they are searching,
we wanted to look
into expressions and
see if there's something
that is important.
Because you want to see if
there are strong emotional
expressions, yes.
>> So what is your summary
of the implications for
the theory of intent and
emotions?
>> So what I can see that
the self is before the emotions
right but
there is no expression.
One thing that can be desired
like these emotions are these
knowledge emotions don't
have much expressions.
Maybe they are more
cognitive than affective
because things like boredom,
things like interest.
It's more about how we
evaluate them and not how we
process them in our mind, and
they don't manifest themselves. Yes?
>> Is it possible that it just
takes a longer time frame to
experience the facial onset of
the emotions or
the visible part?
Maybe [INAUDIBLE]
versus [INAUDIBLE],
how fleeting are the emotions
and their effect on your body?
>> I think facial
expressions they can appear
in the short period.
And especially in the case of
the search sessions were three
minutes, so there was enough
time for them to appear.
The other limitation of
this kind of work is that
they say that emotions,
we might not experience strong
emotions because we do not
have the sense of ownership.
Because these tasks are just
given to you by the person who's
experimenting.
You don't really care,
it's not like that you really
have to perform this task for
the transaction.
You really have to prepare
this slide in time, then you,
maybe you feel
stronger emotions.
Maybe if you do it,
experiment again,
we should maybe
incentivize somehow.
Reaching the goal, or maybe
they should them that okay,
you're gonna lose money if you
can't refine that pictures.
Just give them some real
emotion about the task or
sense of ownership because
you're just being there
just doing your task and
you don't feel that.
>> I guess it commands
them to the presence.
>> They already have
[INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH].
>> They can get more.
>> I don't know I think money
would be a confound actually,
if you're really trying to
look at intent and emotion.
>> So what is your suggestion,
should we?
>> Well, I think in all search
tasks you need to make it
meaningful to the participant.
I mean the way you choose your
stimulus is the number one thing
in an experiment.
So if you can't motivate why
you chose the images you chose,
then it's hard to justify
the results, right?
So you would really have to be
careful in how you select those.
Even in terms of the frequency
of the features in an image,
complexity of it.
I mean all that has to
quantified somehow.
So I don't know how that was
all, as Daniel said, I don't
know how you went through the
mind process of choosing those.
But that would be a very
important thing for
us to know in order to
understand the implications.
>> Those were the same images
in the first study, right?
So that you did have
a cross-section of various
interests in the images, or-
>> No, no,
they were different
>> So I have suggestion
just because we all do
these kinds of studies too.
I know that when I watch
certain TV shows or
commercials, some
markers are better at
manipulating emotions
than others.
It might be worth hooking up
with somebody in the marketing
department to come up with,
how do you come up
with the images that actually
make people feel things?
And they're like, we know how
to do that, we do that for
like 40 years on TBS.
>> So maybe if they come
up with the images, or
the corporate of images that
might be a good starting point.
>> There is the Handbook
of Emotional Hesitation.
>> I love that project.
>> Yeah [INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH]
>> And those are clips from
actual movies where the
directors are good at conveying
emotions so
>> It might be that we just have
to be good at it, as opposed to
having a natural interaction.
Or just like putting a camera on
somebody's ear or head and say,
walk through the day and
just get the emotions that way.
Cuz then those are honest
interactions as opposed to fake
ones you're trying
to do it then.
>> And you wanna look
at search behavior, that
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> It's hard.
I'll say it's not hard.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just put a
one on it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's hard.
>> I agree that it would be nice
to have a [INAUDIBLE] of images
that are known interesting or
known boring [INAUDIBLE].
But in defense of this setup,
those [INAUDIBLE] images
are very much like what you get
in a [INAUDIBLE] image search.
[INAUDIBLE] So
they do reflect the type of
images that people see everyday.
And from a perspective of
[INAUDIBLE] to start with
the corporate people
definitely see.
And that is a corporate,
corporate, for a long time
the researchers Image search
was almost entirely Flickr,
so, you know, it was pretty
realistic in that sense.
>> Any other questions?
Criticism.
[LAUGH] Okay.
>> Thanks.
>> Thanks again.
>> [APPLAUSE]